PRESIDENT AT HIS RALLY EARLIER
TONIGHT IN MICHIGAN.
JOINING US NOW FROM GRAND
RAPIDS IS DONALD TRUMP JR.
GIVE A SHOUT OUT TO WXMI FOX
17 FOR HELPING US GET THE SHOT
UP.
DON, GREAT TO SEE YOU.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
YOU HAVE BEEN SURROUNDED SINCE
THE MOMENT YOU WALKED IN THE
BUILDING TODAY.
YOU AND YOUR FAMILY HAVE BEEN
THROUGH OVER TWO YEARSAL NOW
OF NEVER ENDING ATTACK,
SPECULATION, COLLUSION, JAIL.
ALL OF IT.
YET, NO COLLUSION, NO
OBSTRUCTION IN THE END.
I WANT TO GET FIRST YOUR
REACTION.
YOUR GENERAL REACTION.
>> WELL, LISTEN, IT'S GREAT.
MOST IMPORTANTLY I REALLY,
WHILE IT HAS BEEN INCREDIBLE
VINDICATION FOR ME, FOR MY
FATHER, FOR OUR ENTIRE FAMILY,
IT HAS REALLY BEEN A GREAT
VINDICATION FOR ALL THE
INCREDIBLE HARDWORKING
AMERICANS, THE DEPLORABLES WHO
STUCK WITH US THROUGH THE
NONSENSE AND ALL THE LIES SOLD
TO US BY THE CNN AND MSNBC,
THE TINFOIL HAT BRIGADE THAT
IS ADAM SCHIFF AND ERIC
SWALWELL AND THE CLOWNS.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT MY FATHER
ACCOMPLISHED IN THE LAST TWO
YEARS AND YOU LOOK AT HIS
WINNING TRACK RECORD, DESPITE
THE LARGEST WITCH HUNT, THE
GREATEST HOAX EVER PERPETRATED
ON THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
IMAGINE WHAT HE CAN DO NOW
WITH THAT CLOUD OFF OF HIS
BACK.
I THINK IT WILL BE A BIG DEAL.
I THINK AMERICA WILL WIN
BECAUSE OF IT.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, YOU TALK
ABOUT THE TINFOIL HAT
CONSPIRACIES, THAT IS FOR TV.
YET, ADAM SCHIFF, BUT NOW
YOU'VE GOT LET'S START ALL
OVER AGAIN.
YOU GOT SIX TO EIGHT
CONGRESSIONAL COMMITTEES THAT
WANT TO DRAG EVERYBODY BACK.
A LOT OF PEOPLE CAN'T AFFORD
ATTORNEYS AND THEIR LIVES AND
THE STRESS AND THE PRESSURE
OF, YOU KNOW, BEING GRILLED ON
THE SAME ISSUE NOW.
THIS WILL BE THE FIFTH
INVESTIGATION.
>> WELL, SEAN, I HAVE DONE 27
HOURS AND CHANGE MYSELF ON A
20-MINUTE MEETING.
FOR EXAMPLE, THAT IS THREE
TIMES MORE THAN HILLARY
CLINTON SPENT ON BENGHAZI
WHILE SECRETARY OF STATE.
I WAS A CIVILIAN ON A
CAMPAIGN.
THAT JUST GOES TO SHOW YOU THE
DOUBLE STANDARD.
BUT I WAS BLESSED BECAUSE I
COULD AFFORD LAWYERS TO DO
THIS.
NOT EVERYONE CAN SPEND SEVEN
FIGURES DEFENDING THEMSELVES.
THAT IS ALL THIS HAS BEEN.
A WAY FOR THE LEFT AND THE
MEDIA LACKIES TO DRIVE
SUPPORTERS IN THE GROUND.
THAT IS WHY THIS IS A GREAT
VINDICATION, IT'S SO IMPORTANT
FOR US.
AGAIN, MY FATHER'S TRACK
RECORD SPEAKS FOR ITSELF.
BUT HE IS GOING TO DO EVEN
MORE NOW THAN HE HAS THE
MONKEY OFF HIS BACK.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT ALL THAT EVERYONE
GOES THROUGH.
THE OTHER BIG STORY, THE
RUSSIA COLLUSION.
THERE IS AN ENSEMBLE CAST ON
THE SHOW.
FOR TWO YEARS WITH REAL
EVIDENCE WE POINTED OUT A
RIGGED INVESTIGATION INTO
HILLARY.
LYING AND COMMITTING FRAUD ON
A FISA COURT.
WE HAVE POINTED OUT AGAIN AND
AGAIN AND AGAIN THAT PEOPLE
KNEW FROM THE BEGINNING THAT
THIS WAS UNVERIFIED.
WHAT DO YOU THINK KNEADS TO BE
DONE TO ENSURE AS YOUR FATHER
SAID ON THE PROGRAM LAST NIGHT
IT NEVER HAPPENS TO ANOTHER
PRESIDENT?
>> LISTEN, THEY HAVE TO GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF IT.
NOBODY WANTS TO MOVE ON MORE
THAN I DO.
I WOULD LOVE TO SEE
BIPARTISANSHIP AND SEE THE
DEMOCRATS GET ON BOARD AND
WORK ON THE INFRASTRUCTURE.
WORK FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
RATHER THAN TAKE OUT SOMEONE
WHO HAS DONE AN INCREDIBLE
JOB.
IF THE DEMOCRATS HAD REAL
POLICIES TO RUN ON AND WIN ON,
MAYBE THEY SHOULD DO THAT BUT
THEY DON'T.
SO MAYBE THEY SHOULD GET ON
BOARD WITH THE WINNING
POLICIES FOR AMERICA AND DO
THAT.
BUT YOU HAVE HAD THE COMEY OF
THE WORLD, THE STROZK.
JOHN BRENNAN, THE FORMER HEAD
OF THE C.I.A. GOING ON THERE
SAYING WELL, WE ARE AWARE OF
THE COLLUSION.
/GOT BAD INFORMATION -- I GOT
BAD INFORMATION.
SORRY.
I HAVE BEEN SCREAMING IT FOR
GO YEARS BUT NOW ALL OF
AUDSEASON I HAVE BAD
INFORMATION.
MOVE ON.
WE HAVE TO GET TO THE BOTTOM
OF THIS.
THIS HAS BEEN A STAIN ON THE
ME PUBLIC.
BLIGHT ON DEMOCRACY AND THE
CONSTITUTION.
IT CAN'T BE ALLOWED TO HAPPEN
AGAIN TO EITHER SIDE.
THIS IS A PARTISAN ISSUE.
THIS IS SOMETHING IT SHOULD
NEVER HAPPEN AGAIN.
THIS IS THE GREATEST HOAX EVER
PERPETRATED ON THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
I WAS DONE BY HILLARY CLINTON,
THE D.N.C., AND 93% OF THE
MAIN STREAM MEDIA.
THE MEDIA HAS DONE IRREPARABLE
DAMAGE TO THEMSELVES AND THE
REPUTATION.
THE TWO OR THREE PEOPLE, EVEN
THE TWO OR THREE PEOPLE ON THE
LEFT THAT TRIED TO REPORT IT
HONESTLY SIND MAYBE WE ARE
GETTING IN OVER OUR SKIS, THEY
GOT KILLED, THEY GOT LAMBASTED
FOR THE LAST FEW YEARS.
THEY ARE THE ONLY ONES
VINDICATED.
IT WILL TAKE A LONG TIME TO
HEAL.
THE ONLY WAY WE'LL HEAL IS IF
WE KNOW HOW THE FARCE STARTED.
>> Sean: LISTEN, IF YOU
DELETED 33,000 E-MAILS,
CLEANED YOUR HARD DRIVE IN THE
PROCESS OF ALL OF THIS, AND
BUSTED UP YOUR DEVICES OR HAD
AN AIDE BUST THEM UP WITH
HAMMERS AND REMOVE S.I.M.
CARDS AND THEN IF YOU
COMMITTED A FRAUD BEFORE A JDS
UNIPHASE -- BEFORE A FISA
COURT AND FAILED TO ADMIT THE
PARTY PAID FOR THE DOSSIER.
IT WAS NEVER VERIFIED.
THE AUTHOR OF THE DOSSIER
DOESN'T STAND BY IT BUT
PRESENT IT TO A COURT FOUR
TIMES.
THE BULK OF THE MEMO WAS THE
LYING HILLARY DOSSIER.
RUSSIAN OF ALL THINGS.
>> ONLY HILLARY CLINTON AND
MAYBE SMOLLETT COULD GET AWAY
WITH THAT KIND OF FARCE, SEAN.
>> Sean: YOU MENTIONED
SOMETHING ABOUT YOUR FATHER'S
SUCCESS.
RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT.
HE TALKED ABOUT IT TONIGHT.
FOR AFRICAN-AMERICANS,
HISPANIC AMERICANS, ASIAN
AMERICANS, WOMEN IN THE
WORKPLACE, YOUTH UNEMPLOYMENT.
WE ARE GOING ON 5.5 MILLION
NEW JOBS NOW.
ECONOMIC GROWTH WE HAVEN'T
SEEN IN OVER A DECADE.
AND I HAVE NEVER, NOT ONE TIME
WATCHED ON ANY OF THE OTHER
SO-CALLED NEWS NETWORKS ANY
REPORTING ON THIS GREAT STORY
THAT HAS TAKEN MILLIONS OFF OF
THE FOOD STAMPS.
AND OUT OF POVERTY.
AND CREATED LADDER TO SUCCESS.
>> WELL, SEAN, IT DOESN'T FIT
THE NARRATIVE.
IT DOESN'T WORK.
THE BUSINESS GUY WHO LEFT A
BILLIONAIRE LIFESTYLE TO DO
THIS FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THAT IS NOT A STORY THE
DEMOCRATS WANT.
THEY NEED A JOE BIDEN AND A
SWAMP CREATURE IN THERE TO
KEEP PERPETUATING THE
NONSENSE.
TO KEEP PERPETUATING THE
FAILED POLICIES.
AND TAKE THE FAILED POLICIES
FURTHER BY NOW IMPLEMENTING,
BY ASPECTS OF THE SOCIALISM IN
THAT POLICY.
IT HAS FAILED A THOUSAND TIMES
BUT THEY'LL GET IT RIGHT THIS
TIME, SEAN.
>> Sean: I HAVE KNOWN YOUR
DAD AND YOUR FAMILY FOR A LOT
OF YEARS.
YOUR DAD OVER TWO DECADES.
I KNOW IT HAS TO WEAR ON YOU.
WHAT WAS THE TOUGHEST MOMENT
FOR YOU?
>> THE REALITY IS A TRIED AND
A TRUE AMERICAN, BEING CALLED
A TRAITOR EVERY DAY AND HAVE
PEOPLE CHIME IN ON SOCIAL
MEDIA, YOUR KIDS WILL ENJOY
SEEING YOU BEHIND BARS.
DAY IN AND DAY OUT.
YOU KNOW, IT'S PRETTY BRUTAL.
I KNOW IT'S NONSENSE BECAUSE I
WAS ACTUALLY THERE.
BUT IT STILL GETS TO YOU.
IT WEARS ON YOU.
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU TAKE YOUR
PATRIOTISM AS SERIOUSLY AS I
DO.
THAT WAS ROUGH.
EVEN THOUGH YOU KNOW IT'S
NONSENSE.
UNFORTUNATELY WITH LIFE YOU
INDUSTRIAL TO DEAL WITH THE
NONSENSE.
BUT NOW THAT THAT IS OVER
OTHER THAN A FEW LUNATICS, YOU
KNOW, ON THE LEFT, IT'S PRETTY
EXCITING.
WE CAN GO BACK TO WINNING.
>> Sean: THE SAD THING IS
THEY WILL NEVER ADMIT THEY ARE
WRONG.
THE SAD THING IS, REMEMBER,
FOR EXAMPLE --
>> NOT EVEN A LITTLE BIT.
THERE IS NO CULPABILITY,
BECAUSE ON THEIR SIDE, SEAN,
YOU DON'T NEED TO BECAUSE
THERE IS NO ACCOUNTABILITY.
YOU DON'T NEED ACCOUNTABILITY
TO KEEP DOING WHAT YOU DO.
THEY JUST DO IT BECAUSE IT IS
PART OF THE NARRATIVE AND
EVERYONE IS IN ON IT.
MY FATHER, I MEAN HE WAS
TALKING ABOUT THE DEEP STATE
IN 2016.
MOST PEOPLE ARE LIKE I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT IS REAL.
IF THE LAST TWO YEARS HAVE
SHOWN US ANYTHING THAT IS VERY
REAL AND VERY ALIVE.
WE ARE COMBATING IT HARD.
WE'LL KEEP DOING THAT.
>> Sean: WE HAVE HAD A GREAT
ENSEMBLE HERE.
WE HAVE BEEN RIGHT THE WHOLE
TIME AND THE MEDIA HAS BEEN
WRONG THE WHOLE TIME.
I KNOW THEY ARE NEVER GOING TO
STOP.
THEY ARE JUST GOING TO MOVE ON
TO THE NEXT SERIES OF LIES AND
MISINFORMATION.
BUT I DON'T, AS YOU SAY, THINK
THEY EVER GET THE TRUST BACK
AGAIN.
ALL RIGHT.
HERE IS A QUESTION A LOT OF
PEOPLE WANT TO KNOW.
YOU KNOW, YOU HAVE BEEN OUT ON
THE STUMP A LOT LATELY.
A LOT OF PEOPLE NOTICE THE
CROWDS YOU ARE DRAWING.
DO YOU EVER THINK ABOUT IT,
MAYBE ONE DAY YOU WANT TO RUN?
>> RIGHT NOW I'LL NEVER RULE
ANYTHING OUT.
I DO ENJOY IT.
I LIKE BEING IN THE FIGHT.
I LIKE BEING IN THE MIX.
I LIKE SEEING THE DIFFERENCE
IT IS MAKING TO REAL WORKING
CLASS FAMILIES ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY, SEAN.
I GET THAT I'M THE SON OF A
BILLIONAIRE FROM NEW YORK
CITY.
BUT I THINK EVERYONE KNOWS,
AND ANYONE WHO SEES ME ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL KNOWS I HAVE
FRIEND IN FLYOVER COUNTRY.
I SPENT TIME WITH THEM
HUNTING, FISHING, COMPETITIVE
SHOOTING.
ALL OF THOSE THINGS.
I SPEND MUCH MORE TIME HERE
THAN AT RUBBER CHICKEN CHARITY
DINNER CIRCUIT IN NEW YORK
CITY.
THESE ARE MY PEOPLE.
I GET IT.
WATCHING IT MAKE A DIFFERENCE
TO THEM.
WATCHING THEM RECAPTURE THEIR
AMERICAN DREAM.
THAT AMERICAN DREAM THAT HAS
BEEN EXPORTED TO FOREIGN
COUNTRIES.
MOST OF WHOM HATE OUR GUTS FOR
THE LAST FEW DECADES.
THAT IS A HUGE DEAL FOR ME.
I SEE WHAT MY FATHER IS DOING
AND I'M PROUD AS AN AMERICAN
TO FIGHT FOR HIM.
I WON'T RULE IT OUT FOR
MYSELF.
BUT FIRST THINGS FIRST, WE'RE
ELWILL LET HIM FINISH STRONG.
>> Sean: THANK YOU FOR BEING
WITH US, DON JR.
IT TOOK AN F.B.I.
INVESTIGATION, TWO
CONGRESSIONAL INVESTIGATIONS.
NOW THE MUELLER REPORT.
THE INSANE TINFOIL HAT PEOPLE